The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
That see that.
See that that is a representation of capitalism.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
It is exactly what it is.
It is capitalism inside of communism.
Yeah.
No,
but key people poor and hungry and like the best in the world.
The Best I can do is get three meals a day.
Right.
And live in a better place.
That's
how we got po.
We got political.
Yeah.
But it is political and it,
you know,
people need motivation.
They need incentive for their actions.
People that think socialism is a good idea,
have never accomplished anything.
There's no way you've competed.
There's no way.
If you're a competitor and you understand the benefit and the value of
competition,
I'm not talking about capitalism competitive,
I'm talking about just actual competitive in anything.
Anything where you're trying to get a position and it's a very difficult
position.
So you want to work harder than the other people around.
You know about merit based performance.
Like you know,
like you,
you should,
you should achieve based on your merit based on what you have actually shown to
like how much work you've put in.
What you've accomplished,
you should benefit from that.
And the idea that everybody should be paid equally and that everybody should
just have,
oh man will just contribute and just uh,
I'll give a little,
you give the little dose fucks never give their share.
They're never good.
They're never the best at what they do.
They never know how to compete.
They just don't.
It's not saying that you,
there's not some aspects of a community where we should have some socialist
ideas.
Like I believe in free education.
I believe that without a doubt our nation as wealthy as it is,
can afford to have better healthcare,
better education.
Yeah.
Those two things I think are gigantic factors in just having a healthy
community.
But if you want a quality of outcome,
you can suck my dick.
That's nonsense.
There's no such thing as equality of outcome because if you have real freedom,
real freedom,
you're always going to have inequality of outcome.
Cause the real freedom is a guy like Jocko wants to get up at four 30 in the
morning and work out every day.
Whereas some people just want to sleep til noon.
I'd rather just lay in bed band.
I like to go to the beach and hang out.
I'm not,
I'm not in a hurry.
I'm not in a rush.
Good.
I hope you enjoy yourself.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if you want the same amount of monies that mother fuckers up at four 30 in
the morning hustling,
constantly cranking out.
I've got three different things in the air.
Three different things going on.
Projects constantly,
always in the middle of something.
Always pushing,
always trying to improve.
Always look at himself,
always being self critical,
always analyzing what do I have to do to get better?
And you're not,
but you want the same outcome for you.
I think I completely agree with that.
I feel like there's this,
the world,
oh,
especially the country is in the best place when there are more people in the
middle,
when they're,
when,
when there's these extremes.
And I feel like the Pete,
that people that were in the middle,
they've somehow been dragged further out to these extremes because yeah,
having,
um,
like going
far right with some things,
right.
Um,
no,
you don't get anything.
You don't get this unless you work for it.
And you're like,
yeah,
absolutely.
100%.
And,
and,
but like some,
some of the things that go along with that.
Yeah.
But then this,
everybody gets a trophy every like,
no,
everybody's in,
it doesn't get a trophy there.
There is like,
you should get a trophy if you are able to compete to the level that deserve,
that's deserving of a trophy and that's it.
Right?
Like everybody shouldn't get one.
You lost.
You shouldn't get the same thing that the guy that won got you.
Did well and you lost a need and there's a big competition with a big group and
you did better than some of them.
Yeah.
Maybe you get some of the,
some of the pie,
but like this whole thing of,
yeah,
everybody's equal.
I,
I disagree,
I feel like,
but I feel like there's,
there's aspects of everything that should be everywhere.
So when I say that,
what I mean is like capitalism,
like we saw,
we saw capitalism inside communism in that example,
right?
Well,
inside capitalism there should be some,
some,
some socialism like,
like,
um,
like let's look at the major league baseball,
right?
The Yankees,
they,
they're in the playoffs every year because they can afford,
they can afford to buy the best player.
But like,
look at,
look at Green Bay,
Wisconsin,
small market team.
They can win a Superbowl because of the,
of the revenue share it because of the socialistic revenue sharing inside the
NFL.
You know,
it's,
it's a weird dynamic where there are things that,
that apply in different situations,
but like people can't compartmentalize and enough so that these things can
happen and we can all make it work out.
Like I feel like,
like you said about healthcare and education.
Um,
yeah.
Health care and education.
We have the funds for those things to be,
to be good across the board.
But why is it that the schools in this,
in this rich area always better.
They always have the better scores,
but then when you take that same,
you take the same type of um,
effort and you put that somewhere in a poor area,
their scores come up and,
and they can compete,
right?
If they have the same effort from the faculty and the staff and whatnot.
But,
um,
and same thing with like law enforcement,
law enforcement is,
is,
is better in these areas where like,
it's like there's no crime here then this is where all the rich people live and
this,
isn't that right?
Yes.
But like if,
because they also have better law enforcement,
they're a kid.
There are police patrolling that area in a different fashion.
Um,
like it's,
it's this weird thing where it's not equal,
it's not equal and it doesn't like those things should be equal.
But,
but as far as these people live in a poor area now,
and these people are,
they don't,
they have a lot of money because of a family wealth,
because of work ethic.
Because of all of that.
Yeah.
Like every,
but everybody deserves to be safe.
Everybody deserves to have that at the very least.
Right?
So let's,
let's enforce the laws and in patrol and do those things in this area just as
much as we do for this area.
Right.
And put the,
put the money into that because that's a community thing.
Now when we're talking about what they have,
they have nice pools.
Will they pay higher taxes and they do this thing.
Okay,
well if you want that,
you've now that you,
you're safe enough and your education is where it is.
Let's start reinvested in that community.
You know,
let's not,
let's not get,
get to the point where we can afford to be here.
So we go there,
no let,
we can afford to be there.
And um,
but let's,
let's try reinvesting in this community to make this community more like that
one.
But if we have the protections to do that,
then I feel more comfortable reinvesting in this community.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird,
all these things are all over the place and he got to put them together.
Well,
we don't treat our country as if it's a giant community.
Right?
If it was a giant community where everybody's equal,
we would look at all the problem spots and say,
okay,
well there's these crime ridden,
poverty stricken communities that can't seem to catch a break.
So the people that come out of that,
even though we're saying,
hey,
you have a,
there's an open playing field to compete.
That's not true.
Right?
Because they're coming at it with a massive different disadvantage from the jump
to education disadvantage and environmental disadvantage in what they see around
them all the time.
They're around a lot of,
I can't catch a break dudes.
Right.
And a lot of trap,
lot of criminals,
a lot of bullshit,
a lot of different ways you could go wrong.
A lot of things that could set you down a terrible path in life and it's around
you all the time.
And if we tried to engineer society,
so say,
well,
how do we,
how do we have less people that are disadvantaged?
How do we have less losers?
What's the best way?
Well,
you got to go to the problem spots,
all the problem spots we should be dumping money in.
And,
and I'm not saying that we shouldn't do anything overseas because I think a lot
of the things that we do overseas probably help and protect us over here.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of shit we don't have to do.
And that shit,
we could take that money and just fix cities.
Just go in and throw a ton of money and compassion and education and community
centers and make places safe for people to learn how to be an adult.
Okay.